thank you very much
thank you thank you
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much thank you thank you
very much thank you
mr. president thank you for that
wonderful introduction and thank you for
coming out and such large numbers today
at such an important time for Yale and
for the United States I'd like to thank
the mayor of New Haven John DeStefano
for being here and and my great friend
and former colleague your member of
Congress rosa DeLauro Thank You Rosa for
being here and I have two other friends
who like me are no longer in public
office but each in their own way they
made a great difference to whatever good
we were able to do Kurt Schmoke the
former mayor of Baltimore and my great
partner ernesto zedillo the former
president of mexico especially the
president thank you for being here i
also have seen already today a lot of
people who were members of our
administration there five or six of them
out there and so I appreciate Yale
giving us a pretext to hold the Clinton
alumni meeting here today I was
privileged to study here for exactly one
percent of Yale's 300 years I love the
law school I i love my professors and
have stayed in touch with many of them
over all these long years one of them I
was able to put on the Court of Appeals
one of them I tried to torment in class
with disagreements and he lived the
torment me my constitutional law
professor Robert Bork and we had a great
set of debates 30 years ago that now
that I replayed them in my mind seemed
fresh today I was fortunate enough to be
here at Yale Law School was a phenomenal
number of outstanding men and women who
were my fellow students one of them did
become the united states senator from
New York and Senator Schumer went to
Harvard meeting hillary was the best
thing that happened to me at Yale and
maybe the only thing that really stuck
over all these 30 years I understand
there was some discussion here in the
Ale community about whether mr.
Centennial should go forward in the
aftermath of the awful events of sep
tember the 11th I thank you for going
forward it is what President Bush asked
us to do when he asked us to get on with
our lives and it is particularly
important at this time it's marking 300
years of learning at any time would be a
significant event but marking it at this
time with a commitment to be a truly
global university is obviously
profoundly important for 300 years
beginning three quarters of a century
before the Declaration of Independence
Yale has taught young people the wisdom
of the past the analysis of the present
and the importance of looking to the
future Yale has ask the hard questions
and looked for honest answers that is
what I found here 30 years ago
and that's what I see when I look out on
this vast array of faces today America
is full of hard questions now I have
spent a great deal of the last three
weeks in Manhattan visiting the crisis
center visiting Ground Zero visiting
fire stations and police headquarters
going to three schools two of them
double schools because the children were
blown out of their schools by the events
of sep tember the eleventh and I have
found so many questions Hilary and I
went to an elementary school in lower
Manhattan where nine and ten-year-old
students ask me these questions why do
they hate us so much anyway how did that
guy get all those people to commit
suicide I never thought I'd hear a
nine-year-old ask a question like that
the other day I had a conversation with
Mack McLarty who was my first chief of
staff and is my oldest friend we go back
to the time we were three and four years
old and we were talking about the events
of sep tember the 11th and we had a
conversation that I would bet thousands
and thousands of Americans our age have
had in the last three weeks I said Mac
if we'd been on that plane over
Pennsylvania you think we'd had the guts
to take it down he said I think so and I
hope so I've gotten calls from women
friends of Hillary's in mind who are the
mothers of young children from all over
America with a simple question bill is
it going to be all right tell me it's
going to be all right well first of all
it's going to be all right I can tell
you that terrorism the killing of
innocent people for political or
religious or economic reasons is as old
as organized combat it has been around a
very long time if we searchingly look
through history honestly we find it in
uncomfortable places in the crusade in
which the European Christian sees
Jerusalem they burned a mosque and
slaughtered 300 Jews and killed every
woman and child on the Temple Mount who
was a Muslim but no campaign of terror
standing on its own without organized
military combat has ever succeeded in
all of human history indeed it is not
the purpose of terror to succeed
militarily it is the purpose of terror
to terrify and I would guess that a lot
of young people in this audience today
who have never lived through such a
difficult crisis were understandably
terrified and what is sought from the
terror is a people who are afraid first
of all in a vast and diverse country
like ours if you look around this crowd
today you see we've got people here from
just about every country every racial
and ethnic group and every religious
heritage what is sought is first of all
to make us afraid of each other and
secondly to make us afraid of the future
we're afraid to plan afraid to invest
afraid to trust that is what they seek
therefore
terrorism cannot prevail unless we
cooperate it is not a military strategy
it is a psychological and human one we
have to give the people who attacked us
permission to win and I do not believe
we are about to grant them that
permission mr. bin Laden and has allies
misjudge America they think we are
fundamentally a week greedy selfish
materialistic people they think we are
weakened by our lack of a national
religion and an imposed social order but
they are wrong all Americans have been
proud in these last days of the
performance of our leaders from the
President to the governor the mayor of
New York yes to our senators I'm very
proud of my wife and her colleagues in
the house and the Senate but especially
the people hilary and i went to a rosh
hashanah service the other night in our
little village of chappaqua because we
lost a person out of the temple on sep
tember the 11th and i met one of the two
men there who escaped from the 84th
floor of the World Trade Center carrying
a disabled woman all the way to safety
when I went into the Family Crisis
Center the first day a man came up to me
and said why mr. president I haven't
seen you since Oklahoma City and I said
how did I see you there he said you came
to console me my wife was blown up in
the bombing in Oklahoma City and I had
no one to talk to so when I saw that
this had happened I went in to my job
and I told my boss i was taking two
weeks off I got in my car and I drove
here and I sit here all day every day
talking to people I had no one to talk
to and I thought I might be of help I
have visited many of the firemen ah the
fire department is a marvelous
organization in a modern world it's more
like a medieval army where instead of
sitting behind in issuing orders the
leaders lead and so in our fire
department we lost the chief his three
top aides the chaplain and some 200
other officers 340 killed necessitating
over 200 promotions because no one took
a back seat when it came to sacrifice I
think those who believed that we would
be weakened by this have misjudged them
all over America there has been a
tremendous outpouring of caring over six
hundred million dollars given by
Americans everything from a dollar to
millions I thank the work the people at
Yale for the work you did for those who
lost loved ones are feared they had and
caring for them here we are going to be
all right still we must realize that we
have a formidable adversary and a
difficult challenge partly because in
every conflict throughout human history
defense lags offense by a little bit and
we got caught not being caught up as has
always happened but so far the human
race is still around because
self-preservation and decency catches up
and triumphs
nevertheless I think we have to take
this seriously and see it for exactly
what it is I believe we are engaged in
the first great struggle for the soul of
the 21st century we must understand
terrorism in the context of the modern
world and we must ask ourselves what we
have to do not only to combat terrorism
and protect ourselves but to undermine
the conditions and attitudes which bring
to terrorists banner foot soldiers and
sympathizers if I had asked you on sep
tember the 10th the following question
what would your answer be what is the
dominant trait of the world in the early
21st century if you're an optimistic
person seems to me you might have given
one of four answers you might have said
well it's the globalization of economy
and culture that has lifted more people
out of poverty in the last 20 years than
at any time in all history and brought
America unparallel wealth and
opportunity including opportunity for
first-generation immigrants from all
over the world are you might have said
if you're a techie it's the information
technology revolution when I became
president in January of 1993 there were
50 sites 50 sites on the world wide web
when I left office there were 350
million there has never been anything
like it in the history of communications
or you might have said if you're a
scientist it's the revolution in
Sciences we're going to find out what's
in the black holes in outer space last
year we have found two new species of
life in the deepest parts of previously
unexplored rivers this human genome has
been sequenced and soon young women of
childbearing years will bring home
babies from the hospital with a little
Jean card saying here your kids problems
here your kids strengths if you do the
following 10
things you'll reduce the problems
dramatically and very soon babies born
in America and in any country with a
good health system will have a life
expectancy in excess of 90 years we have
scientists working on digital chips to
replicate the nerve functions of damaged
nerves in the spinal cord raising the
prospect that a chip might perform for
the spine what a pacemaker does for the
heart and people thought permanently
paralyzed might be able to get up and
walk and all of this is truly amazing or
if you're a political scientist you
might say the dominant trait of this
period is the explosion of democracy
around the world and diversity at home
just in the last three years for the
first time in all of human history more
than half the world's people live under
governments of their own choosing it has
never happened before and in our country
and indeed in most other countries with
a strong economy there is an absolute
explosion of diversity America is a lot
more interesting place than it was 30
years ago if we'd had this meeting 30
years ago you wouldn't look like you do
and it's a lot more fun to be here and a
lot more educational a lot more exciting
because of that so it seems to me if
you're optimistic and on sep tember the
10th I'd say what's the dominant trait
of the early 21st century world you
could have given one of those for
positive answers the global economy
information technology the Scientific
Revolution the explosion of democracy
and diversity on the other hand if
you're a little more pessimistic or if
you are what Hillary refers to and our
family is our being the designated
warrior you might mention for negative
things you might have said well all
those positive things are just fine but
the environmental crises facing us are
so great they threatened to engulf on
our prize
progress and let it go away nine of the
hottest years ever recorded occurred in
the last twelve if the climate warms at
the same rate for the next 50 years it
has in the last 10 will lose 50 feet of
Manhattan Island Pacific island nations
the Florida Everglades I worked so hard
to save agricultural productions will be
disrupted all over the world millions
and millions of food refugees will be
created and there'll be a lot more
battles out there there's a terrible
water shortage in the world already and
one in four people on the globe never
get a clean glass of water there's a
serious deterioration in the quality of
our oceans which are responsible for so
much of our oxygen and other things
essential to life on this planet so you
could say doesn't look to me like
there's much going on about this and we
don't reverse these we're going to be in
terrible problems or you could say no no
before that happens we'll be engulfed by
health crises the breakdown of health
systems all over the world and the rise
of epidemics this year one in four
people in the world will die of AIDS TB
malaria or infections related to
diarrhea 36 million people have AIDS but
in five years a hundred million will if
we don't reverse present trends and the
fastest growing rates are in the former
Soviet Union on Europe's back door and
the Caribbean on our front door in india
the world's greatest democracy and China
just admitted they have twice as many
AIDS cases as they had previously
thought and only four percent of the
adults know how the disease is
contracted and spread so you can say
well when we have 100 million AIDS cases
it's going to collapse a lot of these
democracies and it's a recipe for Total
turmoil and violence or you could say no
the real problem is the flip side of
globalization half the world's people
aren't a part of it it is true that more
people have been lifted out of poverty
by globalization in the last 20 years
than ever before
or it is also true that half the people
in the world still live on less than two
dollars a day that a billion of our
people still live on less than a dollar
a day think about it next time you buy a
cup of coffee a billion people go to bed
hungry every night one woman dies every
minute in childbirth and that is a
recipe for revolution compounded by the
fact that a hundred million of our
children on the globe can never go to
school at all had the kids in Africa and
a quarter of the kids in East Asia and
the Indian subcontinent so you might
have said that are even on sep tember
tenth you might have said no the biggest
problem is going to be terrorism coupled
with weapons of mass destruction and
rooted in racial and religious and
ethnic hatred now here's what I would
like to say whether you would have given
a positive answer or a negative answer
there's something that all eight of
these elements positive and negative
have in common they all reflect the
astonishing increase in global
interdependence the extent to which we
have seen the collapse of distances and
barriers bringing us closer together for
good or ill terrorism is simply the dark
side of our increasing interdependence
we have not repealed human nature or the
fact that some people see reality very
differently than we do and it was
inevitable if we take down all the
barriers if we open the society that
people who represent organized forces of
destruction would take advantage of the
very forces which have made us richer
more diverse freer and made our lives
better therefore all the great questions
of the 21st century boiled down to one
is this new age
going to be good or bad on balance for
me my family my community my nation and
the world that's why yale's mission in
its fourth century to build a truly
global university is so important it is
very important that it be good I was
delighted mr. president when my former
Deputy Secretary of State and my old
roommate strobe Talbott became the head
of your new center for the study of
globalization and his wife agreed to war
in the rural fellows program actually
said I'd like to be a World fellow and I
was informed that I no longer qualify as
a young leader so today you are stuck
with my opinions without the benefit of
further Yale study what do we have to do
to make sure that we encourage the
positive forces of interdependence and
we restrain and combat the negative ones
I would like to make three points first
first things first we have to defend
ourselves against terrorism I want you
to know that there are good people lots
of them who have been working on this
for years I want you to know if you
don't that there are many many more
attacks which were planned on the United
States which were thwarted by career
public servants and on our allies at the
last millennium alone there was a plan
for a bomb in Boston a bomb in Seattle
the vomit to Los Angeles Airport Obama
the biggest hotel in Amman Jordan and a
bomb at one of the holiest Christian
sites in the Holy Land and a half a
dozen other plans all thwarted there are
good people who are working hard
nonetheless clearly there is more to do
to build our defenses to build our
ability to be offensive to build our
capacity to maximize computer networks
to follow people
who mean us harm I don't want to say
more about that right now because the
president is national security team and
our allies have some tough tactical
decisions to make and I think we ought
to stick with them given the room they
need to make the decisions so far
they've been making good decisions and
we have no reason to believe that they
won't do so in the future I think on
this it's important for America to stay
united we are and we must stay that way
now and I will say again I know it was
frightening to have the first massive
attack on American soil and nothing can
minimize the human loss but let me
remind the young people here that the
century we just left was the bloodiest
in all human history 12 million died in
World War 1 20 million between the wars
more than 20 million in World War two
another 20 million from government
oppression after the war not counting
the millions who died in Korea and
Vietnam later in senseless slaughter
from a Wanda to Bosnia the world has
never been free of violence and we took
down the walls and collapsed the
distances we are interdependent and
therefore all the things that we have
benefited from in this global economy
carried with it the price tag of
rendering ourselves more vulnerable to
those who would do is harm but we will
catch up and this will be handled what
we have to do is citizens is to think
about what else has to be done and what
else we personally can do we have to
lead an assault on the conditions of
negative interdependence and create more
opportunities for positive
interdependence America should continue
to work to reduce poverty and to spread
the benefits of globalization to people
in countries
haven't felt it with things like more
debt relief more microcredit more
sensible trade America should contribute
its fair share to the Secretary
General's health fund to fight the
spread of the AIDS epidemic and the
other health plagues facing the world
America should deal with the challenge
of climate change through conservation
through the development of alternative
energy through helping our friends and
neighbors throughout the world do the
same America should continue to promote
democracy one particular problem we have
in the present crisis is that so many
people who hear the siren song of
radical Islamic fundamentalism and a
twisting of the reading of the Quran and
the teachings of Muhammad live in
countries which are growing ever larger
ever younger and ever poor where there
is no democracy and no chance to express
dissent or even asset in a normal
political way and it keeps the populace
in a state of sort of permanent infancy
in which you never have to take
responsibility for your own lives and
making it better because you never get
to take responsibility and therefore
it's very easy to listen to someone say
your problems were caused by America's
success it's a hard case to make because
people from all those countries come to
America and sharing the success it's a
hard case to make because America last
used its military power to protect poor
muslims in Bosnia and Kosovo it's a hard
case to make because America led the
world in the most sweeping and important
debt relief ever because the money had
to be used by poor countries for
education health care our development
and nothing else but nonetheless if you
never get to vote you never get to run
for office you never get to stand up in
the
public forum and say what you think you
are permanently disempowered and you can
hear the siren song it's all because of
America so we have to keep urging our
friends to find ways to move to greater
democracy and freedom and finally let me
say this even more important than what
we do is who we are we must understand
that this present conflict as agonizing
as the loss was is about far more than
the buildings collapsing and the people
dying this is about a global force with
a fundamentally different view of the
nature of truth the value of life the
character of human community mr. bin
Laden and the Taliban believe they have
the truth and everybody that agrees with
them is good and everybody that doesn't
is evil this great university is
dedicated to the proposition that nobody
has the absolute truth we all get to
vote we have the right of freedom of
speech we have the right of freedom of
religion we have the right of freedom of
assembly and we have the
responsibilities of a free people
because we believe that fundamentally
life is a journey where we move closer
and closer to the truth but because we
are finite limited human beings never
fully achieve it therefore we do not
have the right to impose our iron will
on others instead we try to work with
others and the more the merrier in the
thought that with honest effort together
we might find more truth that is a
fundamental difference and it leads
people to a different view of the value
of human life because we believe we're
all traveling on this journey together
we have come over time more and more and
more to value all life to think that
everybody counts that everybody deserves
a chance but for them they believe there
are three kinds of people they're the
people that embrace their particular
view of Islam then there are the Muslims
who don't agree with their reading of
the Koran who keeps citing sewers like
God put different all output different
people on the earth not that they might
despise one another but that they might
come to know one another and learn from
one another they hate that one in
Afghanistan people who believe that are
heretics to them and the rest of us who
are not Muslims are infidels we're all
combatants in the war and we all deserve
whatever happens to us including death
even if it's a six year old girl who
decided in the morning of sep tember the
eleventh to go with her mother to work
in the world trade center of all the
things that I have seen and been moved
by this last few weeks the thing that I
will carry with me to the grave is the
lines of the victims families holding
their little Flyers because for days and
days and days people didn't even know
whether their loved ones were in the
building when it was hit so they all
made up flyers and they had pictures of
their loved ones this is my wife my
husband my brother my sister my mother
my father my child here's the picture
and then outside and often in
handwriting this is what floor they were
on this is how tall they were this is
how much they weighed all these people
holding these pictures there were
Indians and Pakistanis in Bangladesh's
and Japanese and Chinese and British and
German there were mexicans and Chileans
there were people from every conceivable
religious faith they were all there a
stunning rebuke
to the people who thought they had the
right to kill them because they had the
whole truth we believe in a different
character of community we believe we all
do better when we work together and all
you have to do in our country is to
accept the rules of engagement our rules
about everybody counting everybody
getting a voice everybody getting a vote
people having to show up every day and
do what's right it gives us the freedom
to celebrate our diversity that we can
be united by our common humanity their
community is not united by common
humanity it's united by what it is not
and mr. bin Laden has a political agenda
he wants to take over Saudi Arabia get
rid of Israel and purge the whole Middle
East of all the apostates so that
they'll always look all looked like the
Taliban what a dreary world we have seen
in the pictures that we've seen on
television from that movie behind the
veil what their ideas are like forcing
the women to wear those horrid burkas
beating them with sticks in public and
worse but this is a formidable adversary
because they do not believe they're evil
they believe they are doing good the
most important thing over and above
anything we do is that we have in our
minds clearly the world we are trying to
make that our wealth is not an end in
itself but a tool to allow people to
live up to their god-given abilities
that we have to keep struggling to get
beyond these categories of difference to
our common humanity and we should never
be blind to how hard it's going to be
think of the great spirits of the last
50 years Gandhi killed not by a
pakistani muslim but by one of his own
Hindus who hated him because he wanted
India for the Muslims for the Sikhs for
the Janes for everybody Sadat killed by
the organization that mr. bin Laden's
number two heads now not by an Israeli
but by an Egyptian who hated him for
reaching across the religious and ethnic
and bloody divide to make peace my
friend is soccer been a lifetime
defending israel killed not by a
Palestinian terrorist but by an Israeli
who hated him because he wanted lay down
arms and take up peace this is hard I
thank God that of all the great spirits
of the last 50 years Mandela survives
probably only because he first had to
pay with 27 years the best years of his
life in jail it is hard to get people
beyond the notion that they are defined
by their differences and not their
common humanity but you can do it by
living it and you can do it by
recognizing that it is time to take
America's eternal mission to the world a
mission to widen the circle of
opportunity to deepen the meaning of
freedom to strengthen the bonds of
community we can no longer deny to
others what we claim for ourselves that
is the ultimate lesson of the
interdependent world we're going to get
through this crisis our leaders are
going to make good decisions but in the
end we not only have to stop bad things
from happening we have to build for you
the best most prosperous most peaceful
most exciting time the world has ever
known and we can do it if we remember
who we are and what we believe thank you
and God bless you
you